as a Perry for three won't go foul that  he'll shoot three  [Applause]  - oh one remaining Golden State can take  the lead at the free-throw line  and see Jamie Lily trying to chase Steph  Curry over the screen clearly takes his  legs out curry going to the line for  three again  curry has been magnificent from the  free-throw free-throw line and look at  that 76 straight in the fourth quarter  in overtime of playoffs he hasn't missed  one since to 2015 finals incredible  brother brother that's something to say  to him as he walks past  [Applause]  the Western Conference Finals will move  to Portland Saturday night coverage  begins NBA countdown at 8:00 Eastern  tipoff shortly after 9:00 Eastern will  it be one one former Golden State of a  to only as good a free-throw shooter as  this game has ever seen he hits all